cats guys my name is Jenna and welcome
to episode 115 of game programming so
last time we took a look at the UI
manager we made a UI manager and we made
this basic user interface here where as
you can see we are drawing things on to
like I guess a separate panel or a
separate layer from the actual game now
I've thought about this a little bit and
how we want to do this and I've realized
that there is one kind of fundamental
problem with making a user interface
with our current setup and the basic
reason for that is remember we're
drawing all of this game stuff we're
rendering all of our game stuff at a
scale of 3 what that means is that one
pixel one pixel on our screen which is
one by one suddenly becomes three by
three pixels so that means that and
that's great because we're going for
like kind of a low fidelity old-school
kind of look and it works really well
it's a really nice aesthetic and it's
brilliant for our game and any text that
might appear in our game as part of like
the game panel game viewport thing
however our user interface we probably
want that to look quite sharp
so we don't want that to look low
resolution well at least you know you
might this is just my opinion and I
happen to be the one making this game so
so yeah but what I wanted to say was
that even if we try to go into I didn't
even know where this is happening I
think it's in you our label it's been a
while since I made a last episode but
for those of you who weren't who are
wondering and hoping that I will be
making more episodes quickly that is
going to happen because I'm going to I'm
kind of I guess taking a break for a
Sparky and I'm going to try and put out
at least 10 to 20 game programming
episodes before I take another break
from this series so that's the idea so
don't worry about that you'll get a ton
of episodes coming your way but um what
I wanted to say is even if we go ahead
and do our rendering so one of this will
be the size right oh no that's right we
can't even wear have a size that's
locked to the bitmap so all of that
stuff right we've got this kind of
problem where we kind of want our you
our interface to be high fidelity and
high resolution but we want our we want
our game to look low resolution and if
we take a look at realm of the mad God
then you can see that I mean realm of
the mad God is generally a pretty high
resolution game we're not sticking to
their aesthetic exactly I mean they're
they're high resolution in this I don't
like to call them a high resolution game
because they don't really look like that
you can see these trees have huge pixels
as does the ground and all of these
things it looks low fidelity their
entire rendering engine though it looks
like is actually just rendering high
resolution graphics right and I don't
want to dig too deep into the
technicalities behind this but I mean
relative a god I believe is made with
flash and that is certainly very good at
rendering things like this but the idea
is that that would be at native
resolution that would be at full
resolution it would not be like this
kind of scale factor where we'd render
things seemingly very small and then
stretch it out that's clearly isn't
happening here and you can see it from
the subtle like shadowing I don't really
want to call shadowing but you can see
the kind of I don't know fake ambient
occlusion if you will around pretty much
every tree and every object like that
which basically tells me straight away
it's pretty high resolution and also
this really thin black outline but the
idea is they've gone for low resolution
textures on a high resolution rendering
kind of setup that's not what we're
doing right we're going for a low
resolution or rendering engine straight
up because we're doing that that does
complicate things but the other idea is
yeah their interface looks pretty good
and we want our interface look pretty
small we want characters you know that's
small where it says our attack stats and
whatnot we want to be able to do all
that but we can't do that without
current setup because our viewport and
our rendering engine is actually limited
to being at a low resolution so what can
we do well luckily there are a million
ways to fix this one of the most obvious
ones might be to just make another
rendering engine which I guess runs at a
high resolution and by that I don't mean
like literally let's make another
occurring
from scratch I just mean set up the
current engine so that we can make
another viewport instance which is
high-resolution but what I want to do
instead is basically the same thing
except we're actually going to use Javas
2d graphics so what we've been doing up
until now and there's a reason for that
there's a big reason for that is we've
been basically not using java's
rendering API all we're using out of
Java's rendering API is literally draw
image okay and that's it and the reason
with the what we do with that is we draw
our pixels which is what this whole
rendering engine is about right all this
rendering engine is about is is
basically composing an array of pixels
and then just drawing them onto the
screen as if there were any other image
okay that's what we're doing and because
we decide the color of each and every
pixel manually ourselves right we have
full control over what this game looks
like we can do anything we want okay
because that's the case and I mean yeah
like we can totally do anything like if
I was to just say minus 50 or something
and this is gonna be crazy but you can
see I can change everything straightaway
okay and that's not even something that
it's you know it's not even look at that
like it's crazy you can do anything and
the reason that's really good the reason
that's really good that might actually
be a more subtle effect because I am
subtracting 50 from black which is going
to give us a negative number which is
why it a bit old white anyway the point
is we can do anything with these pixels
and that's great because that's what I
want to be able to do okay I want this
game to look exactly what I wanted to
look like whereas if we use Java stuff
we can't do that however for the user
interface I think is fine because we're
all we're really going to be rendering
there is text okay
now I know you might be concerned about
the mini-map in the top right that we
probably want to implement eventually
remember that can actually just be an
instance of our rendering engine if we
really want it to be okay I'm talking
about for like text rendering and
whatnot okay so that's what we're gonna
do today we're going to basically create
another kind of rendering engine that
deals with Java's graphics that will be
able to render high resolution stuff and
in fact if you're concerned about what
this will look like whatever it's
actually you can actually
just try it out really easily after we
draw our image oh and this is another
thing I should imagine this isn't going
to work for you really shouldn't use
this in the game so you bought this
think of this as like a high-resolution
overlay that's exactly what it is is the
UI overlay kind of layer okay so if I
just go ahead and go G dot draw string I
can call it say hello same as the other
one and I can position it somewhere like
50/50 you can see it right over there
it's actually kind of small so let me
just fix that off by setting the font to
I don't know Arial Arial is a
windows-only font so probably not a
great idea but wanna go and we'll set it
to like font size 50 here oh I'm getting
hacked what is up with you a string int
int is that not what I've done what oh
yeah sorry that's what I meant
not our font there you go because it's
bigger and if I set the color to white
or something I can't spell today what
come on
all right if I said the car to white and
import it no it just it just gave up on
me
you can say we have hello and you can
see that's perfectly high-resolution
okay and we can set out to however small
we want it to be and is generally pretty
good you can see okay now what we could
do if we really wanted to and you guys
might be thinking all of you guys who
are probably bit experienced and whatnot
might be thinking why don't you use Java
to generate a font basically to generate
all your all your font cliffs and
rasterize them and then simply take them
into a pixel array and overlay them and
basically integrate them into the engine
is just a bunch of pixels like any other
sprite you could do that but
unfortunately that is not gonna work in
our case because it will still be scaled
up by three okay it will still be scaled
up by three because that's how how our
engine works as far as our entire
rendering engine is concerned we are
dealing with a resolution of 300 by one
six eight that's it that's all we can do
okay in the very last step once we've
already rasterized everything and
rendered it it then gets drawn at a
different resolution because if I did
draw it at width times height you would
see that it would look like this and it
actually probably won't remove the
background this is look very very weird
but that's what it will look like
let me is that the right no it's really
not it's just with height
there we go so if I did this you can see
this is what our game actually looks
like in this corner here and I apologize
for the let's just quickly fill in a
rectangle
with that so that you can actually see
what it would look like so that's what
it would look like this is what our game
actually looks like when it when it gets
friended and then what we're doing is
we're saying let's literally stretch it
up a bit but what I mean is the
rendering engine is concerned with this
resolution which means that we can't
actually do what I described earlier
which is just taking the pixels from
java's kind of text generation or even
using something like freetype to
generate our own glyphs and rasterize
them you're not gonna work in this case
and really it's a lot of work and the
performance won't be great either
because it's just it's just an extra
step that we're doing for no apparent
reason but that's the idea so if I get
rid of this and go back to drawing this
image and basically with time scale or
I'm just doing get with get high which
gets the height and width of Windows and
fills the window whatever resolution
that might be you can see we get this
going on here
fantastic so there we go but the point
is we want to be able to do stuff like
this okay so that's what we're gonna do
this is kind of an explanation episode
and whatnot so I hope you guys enjoyed
it I'm not going to end it here
obviously we've just started as a
meeting on for like 11 minutes but I'm
going to explain the general setup of
this engine and we'll we'll do something
like that so that is the plan let's stop
drawing all this stuff I'll go back to
what we had before which was this okay
so how's this going to work well it's a
good question because I don't actually
know I haven't looked at this code you
know fair while so let's take a look at
what our screen looks like and this is
gonna be good great like a great
refresher here you guys as well if you
haven't looked at this in a while so the
way we draw stuff right now is pretty
basic we've got a screen class and yeah
and we just draw things what we want to
be able to do right is for our entire UI
setup right now we're still rendering it
with a screen okay what we want to do is
something slightly differently rather
slightly different okay we want to
instead of taking the screen screen we
want to basically taking a Javas
graphics object the other thing we want
to be able to do is in our game here
we want to be able to instead of having
to do this before this pixel start which
as you can see we do here your white man
chat or render we want to do this
afterwards over here
the reason yeah so that will the reason
we want to do that obviously is because
we want to do it as an overlay on top of
our rendering engine okay now it
shouldn't matter because we're actually
going to change this slightly so that it
doesn't fill in the whole area okay so
right now you can see we are rendering
hello but that doesn't actually matter
this game is actually still rendering
all across here
it's then getting overwritten by a bunch
of I guess I don't know extra pixels to
make up this gray background and whatnot
so we will reduce our rendering area so
that's not the case so in that case it
wouldn't even matter what order you
render it in it's just that we will be
rendering it at a separate write to this
so what we want to be able to do is
basically call UI manager dot render
with probably Java's graphics object the
other thing is once we dispose the
graphic subject we do need to recreate
it which is what happens by BS not get
raw graphics and because of that process
it's also big complicated to just be
like let's let's set a graphics object
in a call in a screen say up here and
then we don't have to refresh it we
actually do which is why it's perfect if
it goes into here now the other main
problem is that we actually can't kind
of function at a at the level we're at
right now because when we do stuff in UI
manager or UI component or whatever all
this oldest vector 2i stuff all of this
positioning of things screen door and
sprite at that particular position
you know we've created one an 81 6 8
whatever that is you can probably tell
by reading stuff like 80 and one six
eight is actually relative to this
resolution of course because we were
using our rendering engine which only
knows about this resolution yeah
Java graphics is a bit differently it
actually functions based on the size of
the window okay because it's per pixel
not per 3 pixels which is kind of what
we're doing so because of that we need
to make a decision whether or not we
want to deal with that anyway because if
we do we need to divide everything by 3
or rather multiply everything
by three so again I'm not sure if you
really want to do with deal without a
what not but you certainly can I'm
trying to desperately think right now
while I'm talking whether or not this
kind of new rendering engine and will
actually have anything to do with stuff
other than UI manager because if it
doesn't then what I basically written
right now is actually really good
however if it does better that if it
does then it will be better to make like
a class for it and actually set it up
properly but I think this is fine I'm
just gonna go with it
so the best fishing to graphics J for
this support that will grab the G pop it
in here this is now graphics G let's
import that and again screen it run a
sprite will be something else this
sprite that we've created is just a like
a gray thing so we can probably you call
that completely and just do something
like she does feel a rectangle so this
is where it becomes important
yeah so this we did it
eighty why don't we do it at AG well
where where is art because it's relative
to something else isn't it okay this is
where it becomes a bit complicated will
still do it at position x position why
we probably want to be able to make
sprite rectangles as well but this is a
UI panel so we'll have a better position
and effective size and
we'll make a sighs all I say that was
the width and height okay
not the position so positioned or
expositional I sighs exercise stop why
and of course we need a color as well
but we can get rid of sprite cuz sprite
remember is our our engine let's keep
that color though and then we'll make a
private color new color alright so there
we go and that's javis color okay cool
there we go so we've got basically the
same thing we had going on here except
instead of this we're kind of doing of
that round position to expedition to
wire doesn't even want a multiplied by
three which will deal with in a minute
and component on train that will take
energy as well okay there we go so
there's a lot of talking here and a lot
of refactoring but this was course will
yield much high resolution graphics for
UI stuff and then over here we try to
create a new panel at this kind of thing
that's fine
remember when you do stuff like this
okay it now needs a size so I think we
went with eighty degrees so just
multiply it by three of the size and
then we went with one six eight times
three as well hopefully we won't get too
many like rounding errors I don't think
we will should be fine and by new UI
panel I might give it to like really
all right there we go so this stuff as
well needs to be multiplied by 3 make
sure you obviously multiply doesn't
matter which way you do it just make
sure you either multiply both them by 3
or well one of them or good thing and
then multiply by 3 I'll give you the
same result there we go so we've
refactored this legend and see what
happens
ok and we get a nice crash because size
is probably now yeah so let's make sure
that we make this still size equal size
alright so you can see we've got these
guessing result that looks a bit darker
for some reason does it I don't know
does look a bit dark
that's oh no I know why it's because
when I'm actually setting the color the
G dot set go
tella now there we go
so looks exactly the same as before we
of course lose our holo text thing that
we had where are we even doing that
though font render so uilabel was doing
that so now I guess we go uilabel Rena
okay where is this coming from
where do we have our UI label do we add
it as a component I guess we did
component don't render G R K T so we
were overriding it it went on anymore
well go away we're overriding it but
we're not anymore because we changed
that so let's go to this situation here
let's get rid of font I don't keep farms
just not our font so job I don't want I
think we'll have a default font in there
we just did like set font or something
so I'll use like Helvetica or something
I don't know it's on the cross platform
Helvetica so this is the style we want
to so the style I think we have like
enum for that love me no but like a
bunch of yeah here we go we got stuff
like bold which is one I think like it's
physically equal to one we can check
yeah one and italic is two and why not
that's apparently what we got
and then there's bold italic as well but
I know what that is anyway um so we will
just keep that at zero which is just no
style at all in fact I think there was a
so plain it's better to use these
instead of just zero because it makes
more sense clean reading the code
because you're like a font to play and I
see and the size will keep it like 30 or
something I don't know 32 okay so that's
what we have a four so let's kind of
match this stuff so first of all let's
set the font to font we get color as
well let's just make it like pink or
something that'll be like the default
color if you haven't set one just to
remind you to sit actually set a color I
don't know it doesn't really matter
okay and finally G dot drawstring so the
text is what we're drawing we want the x
and y so it will be there stuff it will
give that bit exactly this stuff
actually and we didn't get stuff like
spacing in one hour unfortunately but
there we go okay so it's up to the other
it's up to whatever sets this UI label
to actually set the position correctly
so what does set the UI label little it
in the panel and it set offset again has
to be correct so if we just run this
right now I imagine we probably won't
see anything we'll see something up
there which is a bit weird because all
the offset stuff is wrong so in UI panel
or does a player do that no here we go
play does that so minus ten why was that
minus 10 that's because we had heaps of
padding okay so let's just make this at
like members is in real pixels so let's
just go ten ten ten or something
all right and then now let's set offset
whatever does that needs to function
correctly so you are label you are
component I'm just trying to find it UI
pal now when we make a panel we got the
position it's the offset Ryan convento
Brenda yeah compared it'll set offset
position so that should be actually
correct
oh I believe it might be because Java
draw stuff that's saying from the bottom
left rather than the top left that'll be
weird though I didn't think that was the
case but if we draw it at the very
bottom of the screen which is one six
eight times three we can probably verify
that theory yeah you can see that it
draws it from the bottom left that's the
position real weird but whatever we can
deal with that we could use like font
metric font metrics to actually offset
that so that it is the top but that's an
unnecessary performance loss that we
don't just don't need okay cool so there
we go so now we've got this in high
resolution and it looks exactly the same
as it did before it is pink but that's
okay point is it looks the same we can't
actually build it in this life but there
you go so that's the basics of our new
engine anything we can do here anything
related to Java graphics we can do here
okay we could even make a custom pixel
array if we wanted to do something that
wasn't kind of supported by Java so in
other words if we wanted to draw like
some weird mini-map or apply some kind
of post effect or something we could
actually make a pixel array render what
we want and then do that so we can still
do that it's just this is like a
separate it is literally a separate
rendering layer to our actual game and
that's the way it should be okay all
right cool any questions leave them in
the comments below let me quickly just
do one thing and that is for UI
component we really should have a color
for for the component so I'm going to
just grab this pop it into components as
protected
we'll make it public we want to be able
to change these things very easily I
will make this the getter setter
actually for this just because it will
probably look better in card but yeah we
everything else we want to pretty much
get public so that it's easy to access
and since we'll be both getting it and
setting it there is absolutely no point
in making a getter and setter and that
would actually reduce performance so I
don't know why some people insist on
having getters and setters it's actually
incredibly bad in many cases ok cool
anyway that being said we can control
shift over this to get rid of any other
unused imports this looks pretty good we
didn't yeah the color we can set
ourselves so if I'm like I want this UI
label to have a particular color in fact
I might just make this return the reason
I there in second might be nice is
because you can get it to return stuff
so for example I'll show you what I mean
if I go protect public UI label set
color and all these two font as well
minions we can get it to set the color
equal to and I don't know why I did this
in here let's do this in UI components
we can make Col a cool new color hola
and then we can return this and this
will be a UI confront us again if we do
stuff like this then the reason that's
so nice
is because it means that we can do stuff
like you can do this in line so before I
would have had to do UI label label
equals that and then labeled offset
color and then label right but with this
setup I can just simply say dot set
color - let's just say black and then
you can see that it totally works and I
don't have to do anything like that so
that's a good strategy as well price
Reggie okay anyway that being said
there's our text regencies rendering and
high resolution so we had the same thing
same thing as before if you guys want to
use what we had before that's fine
that's actually why I showed it to you
guys so that you can actually use it you
can actually keep your interface low res
and mashing your actual games rendering
engine like like we showed before but
this is the way that we're gonna stick
with it because this allows much higher
resolution text which is important it's
Bella text to be quite small anyway if
you guys enjoyed this episode please hit
the like button and I'll see you guys
very very soon with a new one good bye
you